i don't ever think i may car
ever
it's very dark disturbing and dark what
happened to her mom
i don't know but it's not car or harbor
has
almost sense like that's the destination
this is meant for us to come out on the
other side with
a belief system stronger for it
these movies the original movies that
are mine that they represent where i am
at each moment
unbreakable represents where i was and
split represents where i was
a visit and you name it and then my
father and mother who are getting
you know very old and the what do i feel
about that
when i go there and the roles have
switched
the idea of being renewed is essential
i want to start over and come up with a
new style
30 minutes is a year seems like the most
open space this huge
beach in this cove and then things
become more and more weird and more and
more threatening
that slow turn from something that was
safe to something that's unsafe was
a beautiful goal of ours in the movie
what i keep trying to do as i write is
to imagine
the very worst things and would i
survive that as a human being
emotionally
when i come back out on the other side
can i be stronger for that experience i
want audiences to come
into their theater and never have seen
something like that before
[Music]
you